you fly private planes a lot and you're
creating a lot of greenhouse gases
yourself yeah I probably have one of the
high
greenhouse gas Footprints of anyone on
the planet personal flying uh alone is
gigantic now I'm
spending quite a bit uh to buy aviation
fuel uh that was made with plants He's a
hypocrite and authoritarian control
freak first off I don't believe that
he's offsetting somehow he has figured
out through plant stuff that he puts in
his planes that he has somehow offset
his carbon footprint you have to
understand that this guy with the amount
of houses that he owns the amount of
land that he owns the planes that he is
on I don't begrudge him any of those
things either by the way as I always say
like I am a capitalist he created
something it has value I don't like the
fact that he then takes all of his money
to decide how the rest of us should live